l'épisode final 2 nsight sort
aujourd'hui
mais juste avant d'ailleurs regardez je
vous propose qu'on s'attarde sur cinq
points qui vont peut-être vous faire
regarder la série autrement après
l'intro bien sûr et salut à tous les
amis c'est françois pour la chaîne
explique mme encore ça me fait
extrêmement plaisir de vous retrouver
pour une nouvelle vidéo est aujourd'hui
on va s'attaquer à une nouvelle série
j'ai nommé scène sight
alors si comme moi vous êtes super
excitée à l'idée de connaître enfin la
fin de la série cette vidéo risque de
vous plaire
parce que cette aide s'est prononcée
addictif mais c'est surtout très très
très très bon alors lui mais j'ai décidé
de vous parler de cinq trucs qui vont
peut-être même vous faire aimer la série
encore plus alors ce qu'il faut savoir
avant toute chose c'est que aux manettes
de la série on a lesser vacances ski à
qui on doit notamment la trilogie matrix
cloud atlas speed racer et le scénario
de v pour vendetta
autrement dit il ya déjà du launay et
c'est sur mac os qui dans chaque projet
qu'elle manie a dit [ __ ] de choix
artistiques de malades
même si de prime abord on dirait pas
comme ça et avec sensei tel se sont
embarqués dans un chantier complètement
titanesque et ultra rigoureux et orale
et je fais pas attendre plus certains
comptes directement au premier point je
veux bien sûr parler des décors alors je
vous refais pas le pitch un mécène side
c'est une série qui se passe un peu
partout sur la planète et dans un souci
de réalisme et ba2 grandiose tout
simplement les soeurs makowsky ont
décidé de tourner les scènes dans les
vrais lieux où elles se trouvent
autrement dit là où on a souvent des
décors créés sur fond vert par
ordinateur et c'est là que dalle
c'est du vrai vrai de vrai et ça se voit
et par conséquent le tournage a eu lieu
dans une bonne dizaine de villes et tout
autant de pays à tel point qu'on a les
mêmes des équipes de tournage dédié par
lieu par pays par bill genre chicago san
francisco reykjavík berlin londres
nairobi
enfin voilà truc de malade quoi et pour
la petite histoire il ya une scène de
course poursuite qui se déroule à
nairobi qui a nécessité la bagatelle de
700 figurants 200 voitures et un
hélicoptère
et c'est des gens ça que la série elle
est dingue visuellement c'est que on a
pas de triche
on a des vrais décors on n'a pas de fond
vert on n'a pas d'artifices on est dans
le vrai et les soeurs ma cops qui sont
allés chercher des décors grandioses
des décors réels et c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que la série a failli ne pas
avoir de fin budget deux malades mais
heureusement les fans se sont mobilisés
pour qu'on ait un épisode final et ça
s'écrit deuxième point qui va nous
intéresser aujourd'hui c'est ce que
j'appellerais le slow mot mais le slow
mots quand il le faut alors c'est pas
nouveau déjà depuis matrix avec les
soeurs à gauche ce qui on avait des
plans au ralenti assez épique et balade
en scène ça y est on a aussi des
superbes plans en slow motion mais qui
sont faits avec beaucoup de goût le slow
motion omis c'est beau c'est sympa c'est
super cinématiques mais quand on le met
un petit peu partout sans raison bah on
perd en efficacité on perd en impact sur
le spectateur là le slow motion on le
retrouve dans des moments vraiment
spécifique c'est à dire qu'on va avoir
du slow motion pour des scènes d'action
notamment qui vont les rendre encore
plus dramatique mais on a aussi un effet
hypnotique notamment quand on a banni
huit personnages qui font des trucs qui
peuvent interdits aux moins de 18 ans et
qui retranscrit un petit peu l' espèce
de transe dans lesquelles ils sont donc
on a vraiment du slow motion et de la
technique au service d'un scénario et ça
c'est vraiment cool merci pour ça les
soeurs ma cops
ah oui et le slow motion si vous savez
pas comment ça marche tout simplement on
va filmer à plus de 24 images par
seconde pour pouvoir avoir plein d'image
par seconde les étirer et avoir un
ralenti qui va être fluide 24 images par
seconde c'est le format standard que
vous avez dans toutes les séries et les
films américains et vous pouvez le faire
aussi chez vous avec votre smartphone à
une bien plus petite échelle un bien sûr
en réglant les images par seconde à 60
120 ou 240
allez on enchaîne troisième point qui
fait que la série est visuellement super
impactante je vais vous parler des
couleurs
bon ok la série les filmer avec une
caméra quatre cas sony de ouf qui qui
est juste énormissime
mais là où ça y est se démarque encore
c'est par ses couleurs ou plutôt sa
colorimétrie
si vous faites attention dans beaucoup
de séries beaucoup de films on a une
colorimétrie qui tourne toujours autour
des tombes orange escient le fameux
tilène orange qui est utilisé un petit
peu partout et depuis super longtemps il
y en a qui disent que c'est un effet de
mode mais c'est super vieux le tylenol
orange à çà ou là mais dans ces insectes
on a vraiment une palette de couleurs
super étendue on n'est pas vraiment
quand on est à ces deux couleurs là on a
des choses qui sont très flashy des
couleurs très pop et c'est pas sans
rappeler le film spider et cela sorti en
2008 par les soeurs à gauche ce qui
toujours dans lequel les personnages
évoluent dans un univers ultra coloré
limite cartoonesque
ben là encore une fois on a quelque
chose en plus de ces décors qui sont
grandioses est magnifique on a un
traitement des couleurs qui les met en
valeur et qui va refléter toutes les
couleurs réelles de ces lieux qui sont
pour le moins assez fantastique donc
pour la couleur sensei encore une fois
carton plein mais que serait la couleur
sans le point que nous allons évoquer
tout de suite c'est à dire la lumière
alors vous l'a certainement dit on ne
fait pas de photos ou de vidéos en
contre jour c'est moche on va rien voir
ben je vous laisse juger par vous même
voilà le contre jour c'est pas forcément
une mauvaise chose alors nous à notre
petit niveau avec notre matériel on va
peut-être pas forcément à voir autre
chose qu'une silhouette noire avec un
fonds qui va être exposée correctement
même si on va pouvoir rattraper des
choses en post production sur notre
logiciel de montage
mais si on distingue beaucoup plus de
détails tout simplement parce que la
caméra utilisée à ce qu'on appelle une
grande plage dynamique c'est-à-dire qu'à
une exposition données elle va arriver à
capter des détails dans les tons sombres
sans avoir des noirs qui vont être
complètement dégueulasse et écraser et
aussi en même temps dans les tons clairs
sans avoir des blancs qui vont être
complètement cramé lse rakowski badens
nsight elle aime bien jouer avec la
lumière du soleil avec le contre jour
avec ses petits rayons chaleureux voire
même avec des artefacts qu'on appelle
des fleurs qui vont être des réflexions
qui vont être faites sur la lentille
utilisé pour la caméra alors pareil
toujours petite astuce si nous on veut
gagner en plage dynamique et qu'on n'a
pas une caméra
2 ou fabre on va aussi pouvoir filmer en
flat ou en log je vous en parle
d'ailleurs dans la vidéo qui s'affiche
ici sur laquelle vous pouvez cliquer on
va arriver avec ses réglages à récupérer
un petit peu plus de plage dynamique que
si on utilisait un mode standard et puis
en termes de lumière on le dira jamais
assez mais la golden hour c'est le graal
de tous les vidéastes ou les
photographes et c'est un truc tout bête
qui marche à tous les coups la golden
hour ça consiste à filmer à un moment
précis de la journée
c'est à dire grosso modo une demi heure
avant et après le lever et le coucher du
soleil
et c'est le moment de la journée où on
aura la lumière la plus douce la plus
flatteuse et les couleurs les plus
jolies et donc pas réciproque le moment
le moins adapté pour filmer dans la
journée tout simplement c'est midi c'est
quand le soleil est le plus haut dans le
ciel
on préférera avoir un soleil qui est pas
le matin très tôt ou le soir juste avant
la nuit et d'ailleurs il ya même des as
pour les gens un petit peu feignant
comme moi pour savoir exactement quand
se situe la golden hour je vous en mets
quelques unes dans la description
donc voilà la lumière c'est assez
flagrant quand vous regarderez scène ça
y est elle est utilisée de façon très
intelligente au moment du tournage
enfin le dernier point que je voulais
aborder avec vous qui est un point
essentiel selon moi dans ce sens''
heights et la sobriété des effets
spéciaux
alors cette série elle aurait pu se
prêter à des effets visuels en 3d à
l'appel leurs puces prêter voilà comme
c'est du fantastique à des choses assez
assez folle et finalement on se rend
compte qu'on a quelque chose de très
organique déjà on en parlait au niveau
des décors 1 on est sur du vrai décor et
là encore ben on a très peu d'effets
spéciaux rajouté en post production
si ce n'est les explosions etc et très
souvent les éléments un peu fantastique
de la série bat sont retranscrits par
des mouvements de caméra ou par des
choses très très simple je vous prends
un exemple les personnages peuvent
switcher les uns dans le corps des
autres et on aurait pu avoir ici un
espèce de morphing dégueulasse ou des
choses qui seraient très retravailler en
post production
mais non les saragosse qui l ont décidé
de retranscrire ça tout simplement par
des quote parts d une transition qui
sont même pas des transitions
logiciel ce sont des transitions
manuelles comme ici par exemple où on
voit un personnage passe et hop un petit
faux mouvement et hop le personnage qui
a changé derrière ça c'est pas fait du
tout en post production s'est fait à la
main avec la caméra tout simplement
et ça c'est très fort et ça donne une
cohérence en fait où tout où on a
vraiment une réalisation qui va être à
mon sens très organique qui va pas être
quelque chose de très travaillée par
ordinateur ça amène quelque chose de
très humain qui va donner un aspect
réaliste presque plausible à la série
tout ça parce qu'on n'a pas fait trop de
choses en post-production tout ça parce
qu'on n'a pas mis trop d'effets spéciaux
trop de 3d trop d'after effects bon et
peut-être aussi est franchement j'espère
pas mais que le budget pharaonique qui a
été engloutie dans la série ballet sait
plus trop de place aux effets spéciaux
rennes pour ça quand même merci les
soeurs mac os qui ça fait du bien
d'avoir une série fantastique sans avoir
trois tonnes d'effets en 3d rajouter en
plus et voilà les amis on a fait le tour
un petit peu de ce que je voulais vous
dire sur cette série si les cette vidéo
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à mettre un
coup de blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui se situe juste en dessous de cette
vidéo pensez à vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà fait et puis comme toujours
bien entendu rester curieux et moi je
vous dis à très bientôt pour une
prochaine vidéo
il
[Musique]